hey everyone how's it going so the next
few nights I'm going to be posting every
night updating you all on everything
that's happening during this crazy week
for Marvel
so tonight during Monday Night Football
we have the premiere of the Captain
Marvel trailer the game starts at 8:20
p.m. Eastern Time in the US and it's
said to premiere at halftime so the
first trailer that we got for Captain
Marvel was a teaser trailer so this is
the first full trailer so expect to
learn a little bit more about the story
then we have the Avengers 4 trailer that
is set to come out on Wednesday a bunch
of people have been asking me where you
can watch it just so you know the
Captain Marvel trailer will premiere
during Monday Night Football but then it
will immediately be on YouTube there has
been talk for Avengers for that it might
actually just premiere directly to
YouTube and not anywhere on TV now there
is a rumor going around right now that
it may get pushed back due to the
passing of President George HW Bush
however this is just the rumor for right
now as far as we know it's still
scheduled to come out on Wednesday
trailer dates are subject to change
apparently Captain Marvel was supposed
to be Wednesday and Avengers for tonight
but they switched them if I hear
anything and I hear that it's changed in
any way I will let you know but again as
of right now it's still scheduled for
Wednesday and then on Thursday the
Avengers project game is supposed to be
revealed fully for the first time and
then to top it all off there have been
reports that spider-man far from home is
supposed to aired this week as well and
I seriously doubt that they would
release the far from home trailer before
they release the Avengers 4 trailer
again as far as anyone is concerned it's
still Wednesday but I will definitely
let you all know if anything changes be
sure to enjoy the Captain Marvel trailer
tonight I'll be sure to do a breakdown
video of it right after it releases and
be sure to subscribe to my channel with
the notifications turned on so you can
stay up to date on everything related to
Avengers 4 and the trailer releasing and
if you would like live updates you can
follow me on twitter at the CW official
or on Instagram at the cosmic Wonder
official again I will report anything I
hear be sure to enjoy the Captain Marvel
trailer tonight and as always thank you
so much for watching
woof woof
[Music]
you